Bayern wie aus dem Bilderbuch.
Trachten, Traditionen und eine
beeindruckende Landschaft.
Bayern ist zu einem Mythos geworden und
zum beliebtesten Reiseziel in Deutschland.
Touristen lieben Land und Leute, Märchen-
schlösser und die bayerische Lebensart
samt der dazugehörigen Lederhose.
Die Lederhosen sind toll! Und sehen
gut aus! Vor allem die
mit dem Riemen in der Mitte. Ich weiß
nicht genau, wie die heißen.
Aber die mag ich.
Die sehen toll aus!
Bayern ist so eine schöne Gegend. Die
Landschaft, die Straßen und all die Häuser.
All die Menschen hier sind wundervoll.
Wir genießen es sehr!
„Wald, Gebirg‘ und Königstraum
– Mythos Bayern“ heißt die Ausstellung
im Kloster Ettal, die die sagenhafte
Geschichte Bayerns erkundet.
Verschiedene Exponate zeigen, wie
zunächst Jäger und Holzfäller
die unwirtliche Landschaft kultivieren.
Die Erzeugnisse des Waldes werden
zur Lebensgrundlage der Bauern:
Holz als wichtiger Werkstoff beim Bau
und in der Kunst.
Erst mit der Landschaftsmalerei des 19.
Jahrhunderts werden Wald,
Seen und Gebirge zu einem
Sehnsuchtsort.
Im Mythos Bayern verbindet sich der
Alpenraum mit einer besonderen Lebensart,
und diese Verbindung ist perfekt
weit über Deutschland hinaus
vermarktet worden.
Und dadurch sind Bilder generiert
worden, die bis heute
in den Köpfen der Menschen
fest verankert sind.
Die Königsdynastie der Wittelsbacher
fördert das Entstehen
eines bayerischen Nationalgefühls.
Bergpanoramen, Volksfeste in Tracht
und Bierkrüge werden zu
Symbolen Bayerns.
Die Trachten, allen voran die Lederhose,
werden als Nationalkostüm verordnet.
Bayern wird zum Idyll.
Der Mythos der Bayern ist eine
Schöpfung von Menschen.
Der war…. also nicht von Göttern, wie so
manche andere Mythen,
wie‘s beispielsweise behauptet wird. Das
einzige, was nicht von den Menschen kommt,
sind tatsächlich die Berge, die da die große
Rolle spielen. Alles andere kommt dazu.
Das is[t] die Lebensart, das is[t]
der Schuhplattler, der von einem Einzeltanz
zum Paartanz sozusagen von vielen
weiterentwickelt wird,
das sind die Königsschlösser Ludwigs des
II., die dem Ganzen die Krone aufsetzen.
Ludwig der Zweite befeuert den
Mythos Bayern bis heute
Er ließ das vielleicht berühmteste
Bauwerk Bayerns errichten:
Schloss Neuschwanstein:
mit jährlich fast
1,5 Millionen Besuchern
ein Touristenmagnet.
Genau wie das Oktoberfest: Rund sechs
Millionen Gäste feiern jährlich
ihre Vorstellung von bayerischer Lebensart.
Ebenso bekannt in aller Welt:
bayerische Autos. Und die Fußballer
des FC Bayern München,
deutscher Rekordmeister mit Fans
auf der ganzen Welt.
Mit dem Trubel um die bayerische Lebensart
kann man hier nur wenig anfangen:
auf den Almwiesen in der Nähe von
Garmisch-Partenkirchen.
Die urigen Bayern ziehen sich hier auf
die Pfeiffer Alm zurück.
Beim berühmten bayerischen Bier
kann man hier erleben,
was den echten Bayern noch ausmacht.
Der Bayer lässt sich nicht verpflanzen. Der
ist dort daheim und der ist bodenständig.
Das hat Humboldt schon gesagt,
als er in Südamerika war.
Der hat gesagt, er würde nie einen
bayerischen Bergführer mitnehmen,
weil die Heimweh bekommen.
In vielen Gasthöfen im Tal treffen
Touristen und Traditionen aufeinander.
Alte Bräuche wie das Schuhplatteln
werden hier am Leben gehalten und in
die nächste Generation weitergegeben.
Trotzdem sind Besucher aus
aller Welt willkommen.
Wir versuchen halt, den Leuten ein bisschen
was zu übermitteln, wie es bei uns ist,
die Herzlichkeit und versuchen,
dass sie glücklich sind und dass sie
einen schönen Urlaub verbringen.
Wir haben eine so schöne Heimat,
also [es] gibt doch nichts Besseres.
Ob Heimatgefühl oder Sehnsuchtsort -
der Mythos Bayern
wird von Einheimischen und
Touristen am Leben gehalten.